Oh Canada music black-and-white
visionary director rips off the
inanimate object POV cam from the Evil
Dead movies it's almost like the tornado
knows where he is and is trying to avoid
hitting him with any shards of wood
why is everything lifting off the floor
of the basket weightless except for Oz
why did the Hat lift up weightless from
the basket floor but then stay in place
once Oz put it on his head Sam Raimi
brings you Tim Burton's Oz I know that's
Mila Kunis and she's hot and many people
love her including me but I'm still
calling her Carmen Sandiego as long as
she's dressed like that
also Carmen Sandiego isn't making out
with Natalie Portman in the scene their
teeth are small but very sharp the river
very why did the river ferries wait
until they were being talked about to
start biting him also hundreds of these
things were biting him but he comes out
apparently completely unscathed so if
they're harmless
why was she warning him to get out of
the water scene does not contain a
waterfall lap dance scene does not
contain a fireside lap dance who's ever
given me anything just because they
wanted to and they still have it now
you're gonna tell me no one's ever asked
you to dance before
whatever has movie expect you to believe
that no one in oz ever hit on this girl
because she was a witch
so I hereby swear a life-debt to you you
saved my life so now I'm your servant
cliche oz is addictive monkey Butler's
oz ones up to the witch and stomps
behind a cart and she doesn't indicate
hearing him at all and right before that
she thinks she hears something in turns
and then the camera pans down and we
watched oz have a conversation with the
others for like two full minutes lord
knows what the freakin witch was doing
all that time because when we cut back
to her she's still unlocking the damn
gate
I mean I know they're stupid monkeys or
whatever but this is the most convenient
escape ever movie rips off the good guys
reach a cliff and the bad guys close in
on thing from The Hobbit when I return
with my sister and her army just like in
Wizard of Oz the Wicked Witch decides
not to kill her target when she has the
chance yes for your wizard he will be
the first to die again why not just kill
him now you know what I'd wish for
pretty dress to have my family back
man what a buzzkill I know I'm not the
wizard that you're expecting but I might
just be the wizard that you need well
someone saw the Dark Knight whoa cool he
invented gunpowder now he can upgrade
all his spearmen to riflemen and invade
that asshole Gandhi this movie is pretty
original right up until the copy and
paste three amigos ending so very old
one so like the wind also it sure was
nice of the wicked witches to wait so
long in their attack that Glinda's
Kingdom had time to plan all this stuff
oh I see then to sharpen their axes that
will makes perfect sense now look the
Muppets must have taught him how to
travel by map they are all part of the
Disney family now okay for these rope
trolley things to work someone has to
have gone to the other side of the poppy
field earlier and set something up right
how could the witches forget about their
own deadly poppy field it's not like
they didn't know it was a poppy field
before the smoke rolled in what is she
so upset about is it now a good time to
just fly over there and burn them all to
death or even standing in a forest I
mean what is the point of being an
all-powerful fire witch if you quit it
the first sign of your monkey army
falling asleep once again the wicked
witches failed to simply kill their most
powerful enemy when they have the chance
and instead take her hostage there is no
way on earth or even in Oz anyone landed
that hot air balloon right here on this
tiny spot directly between two tall
building spires wait should this angle
be possible shouldn't the guard rail
from the previous shot block the line of
sight yeah Wow
she said Behold like exactly at the
moment the balloon came into view that's
incredible
so did the wizard plan for the balloon
to get shot down and if he planned it
why did he act so shady about it and lie
to everyone about it go put all those
gold coins in it if he's trying to trick
the witches into believing he's dead so
that he can rise from the dead and
appeared even more powerful that's great
but does he gain any advantage
whatsoever in lying to the monkey and
nook and everyone else about this part
of his plan how could he possibly have
ensured the balloon didn't fall on and
destroy the green carriage they needed
for their big finale which is just right
next to the crash site hold everybody
that was your greatest trick yet it
wasn't a trick man he was putting
treasure in that part of the plan
involved them somehow reading each and
every one of these fireballs to poof in
succession I mean yeah they made that
black powder but when would anyone have
had the chance to plant it all around
this place without being seen also where
the hell did the fiery crash balloon go
in this sweeping shot of the main circle
wasn't it just next to the green
carriage which is right here more
explosives no one could have planted
without being seen
poorni gizmo fails unexpectedly at a
crucial time after previously
functioning flawlessly cliche why is
Glenda the only witch that needs a wand
in order to do her magic anyway the
Wicked Witch is a pretty good distance
away from the Oz smoke here but then
seems way closer in the next shot I mean
the smoke plume is basically the same
size in both clips but she goes from
camera distance away to right up on it
at the very least they deserve that how
did she fall for that after all that the
town circle with the wizard blowing up
stuff and scaring off the witches there
were still two idiot monkey soldiers
waiting just outside the throne room
just in case this chick got thrown out a
window Oscar Diggs died so that the
Wizard of Oz could live really I mean
couldn't you just say you found a way to
get your reincarnated Wizard soul back
into your body again and then just live
life like a normal dude you're gonna
hide away in here forever I think the
people will believe you're capable of
pretty much whatever you tell them you
are at this point I will cherish this
forever no you won't cause gives the
main tinker and Nook actual physical
gifts but then cheeps out with the
monkey and china girl by giving them
friendship and a sense of family
the suck zone here you are here to claim
your throne claim my throne you sit on a
throne of lies
you better hurry or you win will be over
before it's begun
arrows on a moon keep shining from the
desert sky above
you all just got transported I don't
know if you know that we're in a magic
place y'all
planet I'm from a different planet
at the end of the day to another day
over good enough in your pocket to last
for a week pay the landlord pay the shop
please while working as long as you're
able
you know what's better than James Franco
the actor James Franco the author son
dad that's right he's written some books
like actors anonymous a novel and Palo
Alto stories but everyone knows reading
is for suckers which is why the very
best James Franco is audiobook narrator
James Franco from a different planet I
just ran out the face yeah that's right
right now at audible.com slash
cinemasins
you can own either of James Franco's
books narrated by James Franco himself
and you can get it for free by signing
up for a trial membership audible has
over 150,000 books to choose from which
is kind of a lot so if you want to
appear well-read without actually doing
any reading head to audible.com slash
cinemasins today